you know how it is you're brushing your
teeth one morning when all of a sudden
raise your right hand
oops
fascism yes Donald Trump took his Hitler
cosplay to the next level by commanding
his followers to pledge allegiance to
him via an alarmingly familiar hand
gesture I do solemnly swear you didn't
see it coming did you you were too busy
trying to get beyoncé tickets to notice
the actual formation happening right in
front of you
wikipedia defines fascism as radical
authoritarian nationalism that is until
January 2017 when Wikipedia will just
become this ok but beyond a cadre of
creepy youths the tweeting of Mussolini
quotes and keeping the sequel to mind
Kampf on your nightstand which is really
all we need to know what makes a fascist
a Hitler or Mussolini or Franco based on
studies here are a few telltale signs to
look out for first they must have a
strong man complex we will win and we
will win and we will win espouse intense
nationalism we're gonna make America
great again and you'll say ok silence
political dissent bully the media we're
gonna open up those libel laws with me
then that protected bully the weak I
don't know what I said I'll celebrate
ignorance I magically educated celebrate
violence and I'd bring back a hell of a
lot worse than waterboarding fear
immigrants we need to build a wall fear
religious minorities total and complete
shutdown of Muslims entering the United
States and have a messed up dong I
guarantee you there's no problem I
guarantee oh there's totally a problem
what Trump isn't just fascist he's a rat
fascist a rashes one who makes rash
decisions as a matter of policy unless
he doesn't feel like it one of the
conditions that help a country stumble
in the oops fascism well in the case of
Italy fascism arose when the country was
broke after spending so much money on
World War one and was played with
unemployment now I could point out how
that parallels America's condition but
in Trump's America there are no
parallels only perpendiculars and
Mussolini was also a showman according
to this 1929 news clip Mussolini likes
the spectacular you can always depend on
Mussolini to put on a good show oh my
god if I find out Mussolini's
catchphrase was you're fired in Italian
two other things needed for fascism
economic crisis and a bunch of political
elites who underestimate your strength
which is in part what gave ate off his
popularity even though Chancellor Hitler
is often considered by some to be
power-hungry and tempestuous some German
watchers believe he will be less
dangerous than government office than he
is in the street commanding his
stormtroopers less dangerous in
government the scariest part is even
everyday German Spanish and Italians
didn't take the threat of fascism
seriously just take a look at this
archival footage that we recently
recovered far-right nationalism has
gripped Europe but what do your pians
think of their up-and-coming politicians
Hitler he tells it like it is hunt is
nine afraid to speak his mind he simply
says about her off sinking yeah he
represented the asylums majority all the
thing he'd say about Islam he only your
King is the yoke hi mama mia he how you
say not politically correct
Mussolini he'll want to make Italian run
day again
and the last thing to know about
fascists if they don't win they come
back so let's all promise that we will
not be fooled by fascists oopsie